Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2 teases an awesome
new character we can look forward to seeing
in the future Marvel Cosmic Universe, including
Guardians Vol. 3, the final movie in James
Gunn's trilogy.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this this video, I'm going to explain
and break down what the end-credits tease
of the comic-book character Adam Warlock means
for potential storylines in Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol. 3 and also Avengers 4.
Don't forget my Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
2 giveaway is also running here and for a
chance to win just subscribe and leave a comment
on this video.
And there'll be full details about the giveaway
and prizes at the end.
Obviously, there are spoilers ahead for Guardians
Vol. 2 and speculation about the future MCU.
So, if you prefer, a spoiler-free video, you
can tap in the top-right of the screen for
my Guardians 2 movie review.
Let's start with a brief reminder of the mid-credits
scene, which opens with Ayesha, the High Priestess
of the Sovereign race, sitting slumped in
front of a wall of gold birthing pods.
Ayesha reveals that she's created "the next
step in [the Sovereign's] evolution", a being
"more powerful, more beautiful, more capable
of destroying the Guardians of the Galaxy",
who she says she'll call Adam.
All of which is a huge tease for Adam Warlock
appearing in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
3.
By the way, Adam's birthing pod in this scene
has some similarities to the cocoon we saw
with the Collector in the first Guardians
movie and which many people at the time thought
could have been an Adam Warlock easter egg.
This time around though, the pod definitely
is a nod to the cocoon in which the gold-skinned
Adam Warlock was formed in the comics.
Warlock was created in Fantastic Four #66
by a group of scientists called the Enclave
who sought to genetically engineer a perfect
race of human beings that could rule over
the world.
Initially, the character had no name, and
was only referred to as "Him", and I liked
the movie's subtle call-out to that fact when
Ayesha says, "I think I shall call him…
Adam."
Ayesha thinks she's created a powerful antagonist
to the Guardians of the Galaxy.
But I wonder if she might get a nasty surprise
when Adam finally emerges from his birthing
pod, as in the comics, Adam's creators were
also going to manipulate him to do their bidding,
but that did not end well for them as he didn't
like their nefarious plans and escaped pretty
sharpish, leaving behind a scene of devastation.
On the other hand, it's possible that when
Adam appears properly in the next Guardians
movie, he'll feel a kind of kinship or connection
with Ayesha because they've both been created
in birthing pods, and designed to be physically
and mentally impeccable, as all the Sovereign
people are.
By the way, in the comics, like Adam Warlock,
Ayesha was also created by the Enclave group
of scientists and lashed out against them.
Her comic-book backstory is rather complicated,
but suffice to say that in one of her early
forms, she was known as "Her", before taking
on the name of Kismet, and later Ayesha.
OK, getting back to Adam Warlock: in the comics,
later he becomes a member of the Guardians
of the Galaxy.
However, in the MCU, at the moment, it looks
like he's being set up to work with Ayesha
as an antagonist to the Guardians, which is
intriguing because, in the comics, there's
an evil version of Adam Warlock known as the
Magus.
The Magus is actually a god who is worshipped
by the Universal Church of Truth, and I think
there's a really interesting link here with
the MCU's Ayesha, who is the High Priestess
of the Sovereign race.
So, could the Sovereign actually be the MCU's
own take on the Universal Church of Truth,
the intolerant religious sect that went on
an expansionist rampage throughout the comic-book
universe?
And could the film's version of Ayesha play
a similar role to the Matriarch, who was the
leader of the Church in the comics?
I'd love to know your thoughts on that.
In the comics, the Guardians of the Galaxy
stood up against the Church, so perhaps this
could be a future storyline we'll see in Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3.
And I wonder whether there's also a potential
link to another cosmic dark force in the MCU?
That is, Dormammu and the Dark Dimension,
which was introduced in the Doctor Strange
movie.
It'll be fascinating to see if they connect
these up.
Now, one of the major comic book storylines
that Adam Warlock is crucial to is the Infinity
Gauntlet and, in particular, he has a very
strong connection to the Soul Gem in the comics.
It's a complicated and lengthy story which
involves masses of Marvel's heroes, Warlock
included, joining forces against Thanos, but
one of the highlights is that Adam Warlock
not only wields the Gauntlet himself, but
he also puts together the Infinity Watch,
which was basically, individuals who each
protected one of the Infinity Gems.
If you're thinking this means we'll get Adam
Warlock introducing the Soul Stone in or before
Avengers: Infinity War, this is sadly very
unlikely because James Gunn doesn't plan to
introduce the character until Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol. 3, which takes place after
the Infinity War movie.
Gunn has said, though, that as Guardians Vol.
3 is happening after the culmination of Marvel's
Phase 3, the third Guardians movie will launch
both new and old Marvel characters into the
next ten years and beyond, and there are big
plans ahead for the character of Adam Warlock
in the Marvel cosmic universe.
Speaking of which, a comment by Zoe Saldana,
who plays Gamora, suggested that Avengers
4, which is the next Avengers movie after
Infinity War, may be titled "Infinity Gauntlet".
So, given Adam Warlock's connections to the
Infinity Gauntlet in the comics, could he
pop up in Avengers 4?
Not if we take James Gunn at his word, as
he's tweeted that Guardians Vol. 3 will take
place after Avengers 4 as well.
At this point, it seems likely that Avengers:
Infinity War will feature Thanos gathering
the infinity stones to unite them all in the
gauntlet by the end of the movie, facing opposition
from Marvel's heroes along the way.
After all, we did see Thanos wield the Gauntlet
complete with all the Infinity Stones in a
promo Marvel released in 2014.
According to Kevin Feige, the MCU's Thanos
has similar motives to his comic-book counterpart.
In the comics, Thanos' desire to wield the
Infinity Gauntlet is tied up with his desire
to impress Mistress Death, who he adores.
By the way, it wouldn't surprise me if Marvel
decide to use Goddess of Death, Hela, who's
played by Cate Blanchett, as a suitable substitute
to save introducing the comic-book character
Mistress Death in the Avengers movies.
So, Avengers 4 could find Thanos wielding
the power of the Gauntlet and also still battling
Marvel's heroes, hence its rumoured subtitle,
Infinity Gauntlet, as in the comics, Thanos
used the Gauntlet to obliterate half the population
in the universe for Mistress Death.
It would seem a shame, given Adam Warlock's
history with the Infinity Gems in the comics,
if he had no role whatsoever in getting the
Infinity Stones back from Thanos.
Or if he wasn't put in charge of safekeeping
the Gauntlet and the Stones, as he did by
forming the Infinity Watch in the comics.
But maybe that could happen in Guardians Vol.
3?
So, are you excited to see Adam Warlock joining
the Marvel Cosmic Universe?
Do you have any theories on how he could fit
into Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3 and the
rest of the MCU?
And who would you like to see cast in the
role?
Don't forget to comment and subscribe to enter
my Guardians 2 giveaway.
The prizes include two awesome hardback books
from DK, Guardians of the Galaxy: The Ultimate
Guide to the Cosmic Outlaws, which takes an
in-depth look at iconic characters, issues
and storylines from the comics.
And I've also got a selection of three very
cool Guardians Funko Pop vinyl figures.
So, make sure you hit the bell to turn on
notifications so you stay up-to-date with
all my new videos.
And if you enjoyed this video, do hit that
thumbs-up button and check out more of my
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2 and Marvel
videos right here!
Thanks for watching and see you next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!